nous sommes le 12 novembre 2019 au port
du Pirée le Premier ministre grec
Kyriacos mitzotakis marche aux côtés du
Président de la République populaire de
Chine exige inping tous deux affichent
leur plus beau sourire autrefois en
perte de vitesse ce port dans lequel la
Chine a massivement investi et devenue
cette année-là le plus important de
toute la Méditerranée
cette scène est présentée comme la
réussite d'un modèle celui d'un
développement à la chinoise harmonieux
équitable et surtout profitable un
modèle que la seconde puissance
économique mondiale s'étend pressée de
reproduire partout en Europe les experts
et les industries dénoncent ces deal qui
favoriseraient Pékin au détriment de la
souveraineté européenne alors ce risque
est-il réel ou exagéré tirer tout ça au
clair et comprendre les réels intentions
de la Chine c'est ce que nous vous
proposons au travers de ce nouvel
épisode de facture
la stratégie portuaire de Pékin
s'inscrit en premier lieu au service
d'une vision celle de désenclaver
l'Empire du Milieu en le reliant par la
mer et par le rail au reste du monde
c'est le fameux projet des nouvelles
routes de la soie c'est un projet si
vous voulez d'infrastructure qui
consistait au départ à utiliser les
surcapacités chinoises pour construire
des infrastructures à la fois terrestres
à travers l'Asie centrale et jusque à
travers la Russie et jusqu'en Europe et
sur le plan maritime à partir des coachs
chinoises jusqu'à à travers l'océan
Indien et jusqu'en Méditerranée
c'est justement après la pandémie de
covid-19 lorsque les questions de
souveraineté ont repris de l'importance
que les États et les opinions ont
véritablement réalisé l'ampleur mais
aussi la méthode par laquelle ces
investissements chinois ont été
complétés du point de vue de l'industrie
de prise de participation dans notre
terminaux à travers le monde et
éventuellement dans des terminaux contre
l'importance soit dans le maillage des
routes comme c'est les cas de dans le
Pirée soit par rapport à des marchés
majeurs et c'est le cas de Hambourg
comme deux et Bruges ou des ports
espagnols
cette participation elle se retrouve
dans toute l'Europe Marseille Nantes
Dunkerque et Le Havre en France envers
et Bruges en Belgique rotterdamo
Pays-Bas en Bourbourg en Allemagne
Valence et Bilbao en Espagne
Thessalonique et Pirée en Grèce
[Musique]
le port du Pirée justement apparaît
comme celui dans l'achat et le plus
complet Costco il détient en 2022 100%
des terminaux mais surtout possède 67%
des parts de l'autorité portuaire ce qui
place la compagnie comme seul maître à
bord au total 16 terminaux dans 13
sports différents en Europe dépendrait
des entreprises d'État chinoises cela
représenterait 10% du trafic maritime
européen on se demande alors comment on
en est arrivé là les ports ont besoin
d'argent ont besoin d'investisseurs si
c'est Bruges à trouver Costco l'autorité
belge était bien contente de l'avoir les
entreprises espagnoles qui a vendu à
Cosco était bien content de trouver un
investisseur le vrai problème il est
plutôt dans la dépendance aux produits
manufacture et chinois mais on comprend
qu'il y a une forme de fantasmagorie
légitime on peut dire aussi parce que
les portes portent une valeur on va dire
une valeur heure de géographique
géopolitique pourquoi ils font ça parce
que quand vous contrôlez un port c'est
encore un moyen supplémentaire
me poser sur l'approvisionnement c'est
moi qui décide si oui ou non on peut
débarquer les marchandises si oui ou non
on peut traiter tel volume ou pas quand
on sait tous les enjeux qui sont liés
justement au fait qu'il y a eu des
ruptures
d'approvisionnement sont des produits
très sensibles des médicaments des
masques mais aussi
des produits agricoles des iPhone etc se
mettre dans la main des chinois c'est un
risque du jour au lendemain ils peuvent
fermer le robinet
il ferme le robinet chez eux pour la
production et s'ils ont nos ports
stratégiques ou des aéroports et bien
ils peuvent fermer le robinet chez nous
et c'est ça le c'est ça le grand risque
en outre il existe un deuxième intérêt
économique pour Pékin se servir de la
pas du gain et de la course aux
investissements pour diviser les
Européens et les empêcher de mener un
front commun danger qui est celui de la
mise en concurrence des forces européens
par les Chinois finalement vont pouvoir
utiliser ces présences pour mettre les
Européens un peu les uns contre les
autres pour nous certaine manière faire
monter les enchères si vous voulez et ça
c'est d'ailleurs déjà produit dans le
sud de l'Europe autour du port du Pirée
justement en Grèce
[Musique]
l'emprise de la Chine sur les ports
européens rencontre donc des résistances
mais se trouve aussi assurée par la
dépendance de certaines nations au
capitaux étrangers comme la Grèce dont
l'économie chancelante l’oblige à
privatiser ses intérêts stratégiques ces
bataille pour la souveraineté elle est
loin d'être terminée et l'Europe devra
s'accorder pour trouver des solutions
mais surtout exigées de Pékin des deal
plus équitable et aujourd'hui très
difficile d'accéder au port chinois donc
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de réciprocité
pas suffisamment et donc je pense qu'il
faudrait mettre sur la table cette
exigence de réciprocité avant d'ouvrir
davantage les capitaux de nos autorités
portuaires et de nos terminaux à des
groupes chinois
[Musique]